hi reject nation of Danny Rand the
immortal I am pissed sworn enemy the
hand so apparently they have the season
2 trailer of iron fist remember season 1
of iron fist
boy that was nothing too special I
enjoyed it I think the defenders is
right above it I think Finn Jones gets a
little bit better each time I see him
actually just finally saw that episode
with Luke Cage and iron fist the the
Heroes for Hire type of episode in Luke
a season 2 which was an alright episode
I just really thought it would be cooler
if maybe Finn Johns was a stronger actor
it would have been better by the way
over at our patreon we do full-length TV
show reactions I just finished the flash
season 4 over there almost done with
season 1 of attack on Titan just started
Gotham John covers Riverdale Atlanta
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
together him and I cover my hero
academia one more episode the black
lightning left Cobra Kai of course
Jessica Jones season 2 and boy do I wish
I had chosen Luke Cage season 2 instead
this is my city now casual dragon it's
my duty to protect you and enough
backing down
does he look like he missed there's like
three parts I just look like you missed
it oh good shot I'll find a way
[Music]
okay so it's teasing that he's actually
gonna be a hero in New York that slow
down fight where he misses a couple of
times
it's so obvious he's not hitting them
following along the lines of what
happened in the defenders with them
believing Matt Murdock is dead he's
protecting Hell's Kitchen now that makes
sense I mean that goes along the lines
of what happens in the comics - I'm
excited to see Danny ran being a hero
for the people really fight being a
defender on the streets has to be a lot
more than just action scenes man there's
a lot that they need to improve on it I
follow this Twitter account heroic
Hollywood they might have a YouTube
channel to you I'm not sure the tweets
were more exciting than the trailers I
saw Iron Fist season 2 Alice you've
confirmed are you playing Typhoid Mary
which is a big Iron Fist character
that's neat guys Shawn Madden is
tweeting a lot all I'm gonna say about
this next clip steel serpent which gets
me excited because if I'm not mistaken
the solo shows of the defenders usually
have an origin tale to show you what led
them to being them and there's all that
talk about how Danny beat the dragon but
you never saw it so maybe we're actually
gonna see it this time around like some
good course correction Typhoid Mary
wrecking the daughters of the drag Oh
daughters oh the dragon my favorite part
of Luke Cage like most fanboy hype part
of Luke eight season two has been misty
Knight and Kali and winged together next
clip five words punk rock daughters of
the Dragon that sounds like this all
sounds really cool then especially this
tweet here just saw another clip with
Danny and Kali and kicking ass but every
one of the best executed action
sequences of all the Netflix stuff which
is surprising to hear because the fight
scenes were such a big letdown in the
first Iron Fist season that I'm like you
know what the main thing we have to to
who's really ham [ __ ] those action
scenes you guys are dealing with the you
know the warrior the fighter they should
be on the level of daredevil just saw a
clip or Danny punches the front of a
truck straight off and takes on a group
of thugs fight choreography was hundred
times above season one he saw one clip
seems a hundred times
season one daredevil level I don't know
if it's just hype I know it can be easy
to be hyped when you're in front of it
with a crowd who's really enthusiastic
for Hire fist hey you know like it's
cool he hears someone giving good
feedback and I trust you on that and so
I wanted to see more of what this mother
what quitting about but I guess we're
not getting that tonight's out the wait
till the actual season comes out but hey
you know what this is pretty cool a
little bit better than a lot of the
fights that were in the other one anyway
y'all can subscribe to the reject nation
and click that notification bell
check us out on patreon full-length TV
show reactions weekly Q&A music video
coverage would love to have you become a
patron oject today